اشغال قناه كوشتيبا المائيه اكبر مشروع
تعرفه منطقه شمال افغانستان
يعمل فيه نحو خمسه الاف عامل وتستخدم فيه
اربعه الاف شاحنه واليه يوم العمل يمتد
اربع عشره ساعه والهدف زياده المساحه
الزراعيه في شمال افغانستان
هذا مشروع وطني بامتياز والحكومه الحاليه
تحلت بالشجاعه لانجازه رغم كل العراقيل في
بدايه اعمال الحفر عند انتهاء الاشغال
ستضمن البلاد لاكتفاء الذاتيه من الغذاء
او كما يسمى
عربون اطول نهر في اسيا الوسطى ينبع من
اعالي جبال بامير في ولايه بدخشان
الافغانيه ويفصل افغانستان حدوديا عن
طاجكستان واوزباكستان وتركمانستان
وعلى هذا الامتداد تشق قناه قشطيب المائيه
التي حفرت في منطقه كلدار بولايه بلغ وحتى
حيرتان مرورا بولايه جوسجن وتنتهي بولايه
فارياب شماليه افغانستان مع اضافه تفرعات
للقناه لكل ولايه وتخشى دول اسيا الوسطى
ان تنخفض حصصها المائيه
وتتحفظ على مشروع القناه
جيراننا الشماليون طاجيكستان واوزبكستان
وربما تركمانستان يخشون مع افتتاح وتشغيل
قناه كوشتيبه ان تواجه اراضيهم وحقولهم
نقصا في المياه ومش اكل زراعيه واقتصاديه
وهذا قلق ليس في محله
قولوا الحكومه الافغانيه انها تحصل على
اقل من نصف حقها من المياه التي تنبع من
جبالها وان المشروع سيعيد لافغانستان
النصف الاخر
ايسلندا
ونحن قادرون على الاستفاده منه دون الحاجه
للرجوع للاخرين
اسرد وقت ومن اجل تعزيز البنيه التحتيه
تقوم الحكومه الافغانيه ببناء اربعه
مشاريع اخرى ضخمه على مسار قناه كوشتيفا
شقوا قناه قشتابا قد يزيد من الخلافات
السياسيه بين افغانستان وجيرانها لكن
الحكومه الافغانيه تتحدث عن مصالحها
المائيه والزراعيه المنسيه منذ عقود ناصر
شديد الجزيره من ولايه ببلخ شماليه
افغانستان